Hello world, it's Suraj and I'm here
with my friend at town. Hey, I'm a tine,
I make interactive multimedia art and uh,
we're gonna work on a robotics
project together. Yeah.
So I had the idea for a hardware video
and hey, ton came to mind. So it's on,
you want to say what the project for sure.
So it's this idea that I've
been thinking about for awhile,
how the Internet is very voyeuristic
and we're constantly sort of looking
through our screens at other people.
But what happens if now
the screen looks back,
we're going to take a screen with a camera
and put it behind the Venetian blinds.
And then if this,
if the camera picks up a face,
that blinds will close and
then as the blinds closed,
they won't see a face and
where so they'll open.
So what happens with our screens?
Look back at us instead of us just
looking through our screens. Yeah,
this is going to be awesome.
So we're going to show you the
hardware first and then the code.
So shall we get started?
Yeah, let's do it.
But there's the raspberry Pi we're
going to use. What else? So we have the,
the raspberry Pi camera it mega pixels.
All right,
we have a case for the camera
also so it doesn't get ruined.
Then we have this board over here,
which is a,
which is going to be a hat we
put on top of the Raspberry Pi,
which will let us control the service
and the service are over here.
I got an extra one just in
case cause I didn't want to,
I didn't want to mess
up while we're doing it.
And then finally here is the
power supply for the service.
I mean it configure the um,
the operating system to be able to
talk to this particular display. See,
have to put a special config dot text
file on the chip and a particular
directory. And then when you
boot up the raspberry Pi,
this display will work and
not just display a bunch
of like random white lines.
Okay. So we had the new config on the SD
card and we're going to put it into the,
into the raspberry Pi.
And then know when we plug in the
raspberry Pi with the screen over here,
it should
turn on,
let's see if it worked and didn't work.
Oh, there we go. That's where, okay,
so I have everything working and Allison's
working and my keyboard should be
working in a second so we could open up
terminal and start, start typing away.
So right here we have the uh,
this integrated circuit,
which will let us control the service.
And with why this is important is it's
I'm a pwn PWM controller since we're
pulse with modulation.
So the Servo,
which is over here is controlled
via a series of pulses from the,
from the computer or
the integrated circuit.
The problem is raspberry
Pi's integrated circuit,
the raspberry Pi's Gpio output,
which are these pins over here,
which send signals to periphery devices.
Um,
there's only one I think that has the
precision that we need to control the
Servo that we have. So therefore they
created this hat which just as a sort of,
which is a device which will sit on top
of the raspberry pie once we solder it
and it will sort of sit right
over here. Um, and once,
and with this hat allows us to do is I
have much more precise control through a
series of libraries,
uh,
on the raspberry Pi to actually
control the Servo as we desired.
So once we have this working and
we'll be able to, and these aren't,
these aren't soldered in just yet,
once we have this working,
we'll be able to take the input from the
camera when it detects a face and sends
an output signal over the
Gpio pins through this hat
to control the servo how we
want and we'll turn the blind accordingly.
Yeah,
we're just salary and the connections to,
I was very fine.
I'm going to look at it to make sure I
didn't like solder or any of the pins
together because that would mess that up.
So just making sure that
all the salaries done well.
So we'll put these characters in this
way and then we'll show you once,
once we saw her in,
we'll be able to take the Servo
and just slot it right on top.
Sought it right on top of these
connectors and we should be good to go.
So we're checking the raspberry Pi camera
and now we're going to put it inside
of the Raspberry Pi case just to
protect it and make sure that what mean.
So because this is a nice clean servant
surface on the back to be able to stick
it to the wall.
Perfect.
So we just popped the case.
I don't want to break it.
There we go. There we go.
So on the camera there's this little
blue tab and just pull it off.
So we could actually,
it's the camera.
We don't ruin the camera so the camera
could see out slided and over these
little spokes and the buttons
so it sort of sticks nicely.
And then find the, the, um,
and then I think we owe that.
Oh yeah, the divot is in here.
So just sort of this the tab which,
which powers the camera sits in nicely
and we slip on the cover and that's it.
There it is.
Pi Camera is protected.
So now we can play around with it and
don't have to worry about bumping into it
in any weird way and we'll be
able to install it efficiently.
So now we're going to install the camera
through the hat because we finished all
the soldering and we've done
our single set of output pins.
And by this, so we have the slide the
camera right through here so we don't,
uh, so you know, and we didn't
want to do it while soldering,
so we didn't want to stop it at the
camera. So we want the blue side of the,
of the, um, of the camera
facing the black side of the,
um,
of the raspberry Pi because the,
the connecting pins over here
go up against the connecting
pins on the inside of
this connection.
All we do is we slide
it in gently uninsured,
just slipped right into place
up in. There it goes. So now,
now the camera's insecurity.
So if you pull on it,
it shouldn't slide out and we could,
uh, now I'm going to add back the,
the top of the breath of
the raspberry Pi case.
So it kills right over there the
first thing. So it slides in nicely.
Then this guy,
this top piece also slides in really,
really nicely and once one to after
I agree, attach all the screws,
this camera,
this,
this hat we'll slide in and it will
attach into the Gpio pins on the Pi should
just slip it in really nicely
up and their clicks in.
And now the how does attach and it's
not going anywhere and we'll be able to
control it from the Raspberry Pi.
Okay.
The question now that I'm talking with
Siraj about is like how do we install
open CV on the raspberry Pi because we're
going to need it to use open CV to, um,
determine if we'd see a face or not.
The problem I've had and is that open CV
three is there's no pre compiled binary
on wn. So it's like such a
pain to compile it from source,
especially on a, this raspberry pie
because it's just, it's a relatively slow,
it's quick,
but compared to the original raspberry Pi,
but still a relatively slow computer.
So I think what we're going to do is
we're going to install an older version of
open CV so that we could just get it pre
compiled and sort of work in python two
instead of python three even though that's
what I would have loved to do. But so,
so Raj has been videoing me, so I'm going
to video Sarraj back video assumption.
There we go. Look at that.
Oh my God. Cameras work. Hey.
So there are two modules you'll need to
install onto the raspberry pi open CV.
You will let the camera to detect faces
and I GPIO will control the service.
And then for the code,
we'll look in Maine dot. Py.
So other than open CV and num py, we've
got to help our libraries here. Hi,
video stream.
We'll read in our video stream and
blinds will open and close the blind by
issuing Servo commands.
So named window,
we'll initialize the frame that we can
get the images from and then we can start
the contents of that video stream using
the start method of our helper class in,
we'll initialize our blinds object,
which we'll use to open and
close your blinds in a second.
And in this wild statement,
we can continuously get the images
from our video stream and we'll use the
[inaudible] function of open CV
to get the image from the frame.
And then using the redirects function,
we can detect if there's a face for
knots and store that in the rex variable.
If direct is not empty,
that means that we detected a face so the
blinds come close. Else that can open.
Cool. So I'll, I'll,
what we're doing now is I'm up to the
stage where I want to attach the blind to
my wall. So I'm just gonna
put it right here on the wall.
Nothing special because the
screen's going to be behind it.
And in order to do this,
we're going to use these handy
mounts that come with a blind.
We have the,
the side of Venetian blinds nail to my
wall correctly on the studs so things
don't fall down.
Then up here we have the Servo,
which is sort of gently
attached to the turning motor,
the turning mechanism of the blinds.
So when the Servo turns, we'll,
it'll turn the blind to mechanism instead
of the standard like Steck that return
then attach to the Servo,
it goes directly into the breadboard.
So I broke the little, um, the hat
I had last time. And what this is,
is just the breadboard,
which has the five volt connection
connected to the Red Servo vine.
The ground connection to the brown sort
of align and the data connection to the
18th pin on the, um, on the raspberry Pi.
And this is, that's just the pin I've
chosen to do the pulse with modulation,
the PCM output on which will then
control the servo accordingly. Uh,
and I'm using the pig,
uh, the Pi Pg Gio library,
which works really well unless we
do effective pulse with modulation.
Then that connects the raspberry Pi,
which,
which controls both the camera,
which will look at us when we
were in the frame and the um,
the raspberry Pi screen where we'll
see ourselves and our picture. Um,
now we'll close the blinds
and get everything working
gently. Very exciting, very exciting.
So we've gotta make sure all
the blinds are crafts. Sweet.
Cool. So now they're closed
and we'll just run the, uh,
the main program.
So open CV should start working and my
face is on the screen and it doesn't
recognize me just, yeah.
But if I take a step back,
camera now sees me and the blinds closed.
Now it won't see me anymore
and the blinds open.
But now my face is here so
it closes again. So the cost,
they'll go back and forth, blinds, opening
and closing while I stand in the frame.
If we,
if I step out of the frame,
both seraphs and I are
outside of the frame.
The blind shits they open because
there's no, there's no face.
But if we peek in,
they close.
Yeah, it's working. Please
subscribe. And for now,
we've got to clean up some hardware,
so thanks for watching.